And everybody, Dr. Cutters, again, this is step three and it's about cleaning up our environment, cleaning up our environment.
So though I'm not talking about going outside and picking up trash.
That's good too. It's a good thing to do. It's a good exercise. So do that too.
But that's not what we're talking about here. We're talking about our internal environment.
How are we going to clean that up? We can't be continuing to toxify ourselves.
So we talked about dietary things and working on reducing the amount of inflammation, the amount of toxic exposure that we got from the inflammatory process that's going on about balancing sodium levels, balancing glucose levels.
We discussed about that. But now we want to get into some other things that understand everybody's at a different level here.
Maybe you have completely already gone down this pathway. Some people, this is brand new to them.
We can't have, we can't be exposing ourselves to chemicals.
If you haven't yet explored natural cosmetics and natural plating supplies and trying to keep away from plastics in your household and from out of hides and glues and benzines and all these kind of things that we're talking about at this stuff,
then we need you need to start. So try to shave you or anything like that. You need to start. There's a lot of people out of this course that are super sick and have done everything that we talked about so far. They can't seem to get better.
That's not anything bad about where you're at. But we need to start cleaning things up. We need to start looking into poisons in our environment, things that we're exposed to.
You're wearing a grey t-shirt right now and it certainly wasn't dyed with natural chemicals who's dyed with some sort of toxic chemical that is legal in our United States of America to be putting on our body.
Fades over time because those toxins, those coloring agents, dispersity of the environment and I breathe them in.
Zorbs through my skin and becomes a part of me. I need to get rid of that. We'll talk about how to get rid of that through the detoxification pathways of the next section.
Here we need to reduce the amount of toxic exposure. We can talk about detoxification till our eyes turn great. But if we're toxifying ourselves at a rate that is greater than any possible way that we can detoxify ourselves, we're going to become poisoned.
The main way that we're poisoned is through chemicals in our environment and we just live in a world that is just very different from our great-great-grandparents.
The Dow Chemical is producing new chemicals on a weekly basis probably and these things have never been tested until she would expose her.
Certainly not to any degree that's going to be satisfiable to real healthcare.
You need to just take the avenue of the morbid poison that we need to reduce that poison as best as you possibly can.
There's tons of different, you know, crunchy websites out there that talk about chemicals that are in our environment and I'm not going to go into a bit detail here. You Google those kind of things.
That's not what this course is for but you need to start investigating. You need to be open to this and I know you could go down this rapid hole of becoming so crunchy that you're not good for anything in this world that nobody could stand to be around you.
You have to have a balance but we are so far out of balance as far as poisons that we're exposed to and what that's doing to us.
So we're mainly a cancer clinic. I've shared this before. I'm going to tell you the number one cause of cancer is these chemicals that we're exposed to all these different chemicals.
So start looking at these, start looking at what you're doing to your house and what you're doing to your yard and what you're spraying out of your plants and what you're putting.
You just need to go through, I don't know, a couple of dozen years ago or whatever.
My wife and I, we just literally went through everything through stuff away and started changing the way we will use for cleaners.
My wife is just really a stickler and what you'll buy for soap and what you'll buy for dish soap and what you'll buy for laundry soap.
I mean you just have to start being cognizant of all these types of things.
The dietary things, too, even talked about foods that cause inflammation in our body but you've got to look at things chemicals on our foods.
There is a dirty dozen clean 15. I think this is the 2022 list it updates every year but that you absolutely have to buy organic.
They're just heavily sprayed and heavily chemical exposure.
So the clean 15 is the things that have a much less spray to them.
So like sweet cord is on there, oh I can buy this regular sweet cord but this has to do with just sprays.
Now regular sweet cord is GMO sweet cord so this is not a GMO list so this is just for pesticides.
So you have to buy GMO sweet cord where you're going to get that, well that's only going to be organic.
So look at a list like this, you can download them on your phone, there's different apps that you can download on your phone that you can kind of search your grocery store for and you could even scan things in the grocery store.
This is not good for this reason or that reason. That's not what this purpose of this is for but look up those apps, they're very very helpful.
You want to become aware, you know we are, my children perish for lack of knowledge. I don't want you to be in that category.
I know that has to do with spiritual knowledge but it also has to do with intelligence. God gave us a brain to understand these things.
And when we don't use it, I think that God's just going to protect us, that's not correct theology.
So we need to be obedient, we need to use the brain and the abilities that God has given us.
So can you continue studying my friend, I'll be praying for you. We'll see you in the next video.